Psss ! Histoire de ne pas vous saouler avec ça, si vous êtes abonné à la chaîne,
j'ai un petit message pour vous à la fin de la vidéo, après la outro.
Salut ! Et bienvenue à l'explication de la semaine.
Le dimanche je vous apprends quelque chose pour bluffer les autres !
Et aujourd'hui on va parler de sous parce que tout le monde est intéressé par l'argent.
Les gens sont beaucoup plus attentifs sur un tour où il a un peu de pognon.
Vous demandez à quelqu'un de sortir une pièce de 2€, de 1€ et de 50 centimes.
Si vous n'avez pas de pièces sur vous, ou que vous n'avez pas ces valeurs,
vous pouvez aussi prendre trois petits papiers et marquer dessus "2€", "1€" et "50 centimes".
Vous les placez devant la personne pour que de sa gauche à sa droite il y est 2€, 1€, puis 50 centimes.
D'ailleurs si vous voulez, vous pouvez le faire en même temps que moi sur la vidéo.
Mais attention !
Ce n'est pas une mise au défis, puisque après je vous l'explique !
Vous demandez à votre ami de mélanger les trois pièces dans l'ordre qu'il veut sauf dans l’ordre de départ: 2€, 1€, 50 centimes.
Donc il les mélange dans un ordre complètement aléatoire, sauf dans l'ordre de départ !
Si vous faites le tour en même temps que je explique, faites-le.
Ensuite vous demandez à votre ami d'échanger la pièce de 2€ contre la pièce qui se trouve directement à la droite de cette pièce-là.
Et s'il n'y a pas de pièce à droite, alors il ne touche rien.
Encore une fois, si vous êtes en train de faire le tour en live, faites-le et sinon votre ami vous prévient qu'il a terminé de le faire.
Ensuite demandez-lui d'échanger sa pièce de 50 centimes contre la pièce qui est juste à la gauche de la pièce de 50 centimes.
Sauf s'il n'y a pas de pièce, évidemment !
Et pour terminer, il doit échanger la pièce de 1€ contre celle qui se trouve directement à sa droite.
Sauf s'il n'y a pas de pièce ! Vous avez compris.
Et là, vous vous concentrez, et vous pouvez révéler que les pièces sont de la gauche, vers sa droite, dans l’ordre suivant:
50 centimes, 2€ et 1€.
Si vous l'avez fait, c'est ce que vous avez devant les yeux, actuellement.
Vous avez bien compris que le fonctionnement est une logique de  mentaliste à raisonnement mathématique.
Il suffit donc de suivre les 5 étapes.
Mettre dans le premier ordre de départ: 50 centimes, 1€ puis 2€.
Et ça vous donnera obligatoirement cet ordre là.
Obligatoirement, puisqu'en effet c'est un raisonnement purement mathématique.
Donc si vous l'avez fait en même temps que la vidéo et vous n'avez pas obtenu ce résultat là, c'est que vous vous êtes trompé,
ou que vous avez volontairement pas suivi les consignes.
Vous pouvez également l'adapté à pleins de choses différentes.
Par exemple si vous êtes dans un bar où vous faites poser des objets aléatoires, comme un téléphone, un briquet, etc.
Vous retrouverez le placement final.
Vous pouvez aussi en terme de présentation faire semblant de capter les choses à distance.
Vous pouvez également écrire l'ordre à l'avance comme une prédiction, ou comme une influence.
L’intérêt d'un tour à raisonnement automatique comme celui-ci, c'est que vous pouvez construire une vraie histoire, une vraie mise en scène, un vrai délire dessus.
Faites-le ! Puisque vous n'avez pas de temps à passer dans la compréhension de l'effet ou dans l'entrainement, alors prenez le temps de faire quelque chose de sympa.
Et ne gardez pas forcément juste les pièces comme ça.
Mettez-y un enjeu, quelque chose de plus intéressant que de le faire, pour le faire.
J'espère que vous allez vous éclater avec ce tour, que vous allez le faire dès aujourd'hui, ou toute cette semaine en bluffant tout le monde.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'oubliez pas de me le faire savoir en me laissant un petit...
Pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également laisser un commentaire au bas de la vidéo. Vous avez vu, hier j'ai répondu à tous les commentaires de la semaine,
en tout cas je les ai tous lu, et j'ai répondu à un maximum d'entre eux.
Merci d'être là. Passez un excellent dimanche et rendez-vous demain lundi, à 17H.
Je vous ferez un Vlog sur l'endroit où j'habite et où je vis.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner avant de partir.
A demain !
Ciao !
Je vous le disais au début de la vidéo, petit message très rapide pour ceux que ça intéresse.
C'est pour ça que je ne voulais pas le mettre en plein cœur de la vidéo, car ce n'est pas forcément intéressant pour tout le monde.
Il y a quelques semaines j'avais vlogué des images au Secret Studio,
d'ailleurs j'avais perdu une partie des rushs du coup il n'y avait pas grand chose, j'étais assez dégoûté mais j'avais sorti la vidéo car il fallait bien que je la sorte.
Le principe c'est que j'allais faire une conférence dans un lieu secret sur le mentalisme.
Cette conférence est aujourd'hui en ligne sur le site de Secret Studio depuis le 26 mai, je crois qu'elle est en ligne.
Elle dure plus de 2 heures, et je parle pendant 2 heures de mentalisme, des faits, de choses à faire, des choses bluffantes,
qui sont forcément plus poussées que sur la chaîne puisque ce jour-là, j'avais quand même 2 heures devant moi pour parler.
Vous avez été quelques uns, une petite dizaine, vous n'étiez pas nombreux à me demander dans les commentaires où est ce qu'on pouvait trouver la conférence.
C'est vrai qu'au départ je ne comptais pas en faire la pub, je n'avais pas mis le lien à l'époque dans le descriptif.
Donc je vous mets le lien dans le descriptif de cette vidéo. Ainsi, vous pourrez aller la voir si ça vous intéresse.
Et n'hésitez pas à me faire un petit retour là-dessus.
Passez un bon dimanche !
Ciao !